- Facebook's vested interest is if for
it to work for advertisers and
the people that consume it.
It's the only currency they have.
Television has Nielsen's, that's fake.
Facebook's an amazing product because
it's kind of like Vayner.
The only reason we're a good agency
is 'cause I wanna become
the brands and thus
the collateral of my mission
is we're good with clients,
not maximizing our, I
would sell programmatic
in television if I wanted to make money.
- Sure.
(indie rock music)
- I give without expectation knowing that
karma and good is smart and
will work if we even need it.
The most pure testing
environment to me right now
is Facebook.
If you're going 25 and up,
they're there at scale.
30 and up for sure.
It's crazy, all these
companies that do research
and insights right?
500 thousand they survey
like, hey ma'am at Albertsons,
hey ma'am do you wanna
go in this weird room?
It's all context, not content.
Everyone's so addicted to the content,
the content's number two.
It's the context.
I just scaled at Sid, he's like give me up
for a swipe of it he's like,
just make a generic one,
I'm like why I'm right here?
I'm gonna say no, hey
India, hey Brazil, hey Mex,
the context is the ROI.
- [Man] We can to 13 to 17.
- That was that.
I mean, that's gonna,
honestly that's gonna work.
- [Man] Do it without
in line, then we can go broader.
We can use the same video and go broader.
- Oh you want--
- [Man] We don't need
another two minutes from you
and say Brazil, we wanna
use the same thing.
- But it's gonna convert better.
That's the punchline.
Like the punch, like
that's the thing like,
you guys have me.
The beauty with me is
like Brazil, what is up?
You're not following my content enough.
Swipe up if you wanna
win an entrepreneurship
because the dynamics that I believe in
over index in South America
more than even here in New York.
They hear Brazil, I mean it's context.
Did you get yelled at?
- Targeting those fans.
- Did you take it like a man?
- Did you take it like a man.
(laughing)
- Quick question.
- Yeah.
- We have pretty good
relationships with Amazon.
- Nobody has a relationship with Amazon.
- Alright well, never mind.
Is there any value on the
concept of doing like an
exclusive thing with them for awhile?
- Nope. You should do an
exclusive thing on your dot com
and use Amazon.
We need to fuck Amazon before it fucks us.
(ambient rock music)
Hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk, how are you?
- [Phone Caller] I'm
good Gary, how are you?
- Very good.
- [Phone Caller] Thank you for calling me.
- Thanks for the interest.
Baseball said you're gonna consume us
the way we baseball want,
not the way you want.
I couldn't be more down on
baseball 35 years from now
based on what they're doing now.
Kids are not growing up with
baseball cards like they did.
There's new alternatives,
like everyone's like
well, it's a great summer night.
Well guess what?
Do you know what every 8 to
13 year old in America's doing
on summer nights right now?
They're staying inside
and playing Fortnite.
Boxing and horseracing were
the most popular sports
along with baseball in this
country in 1920, 30 and 40.
And guess what?
Now we're in a digital world
and that's who's gonna benefit
AKA ESports AKA things like
the NBA that understand
how to manipulate it and
you know who's gonna lose?
Baseball.
Third tier NBA players are getting famous
and the biggest superstars of baseball
are completely and utterly not known.
I have a funny feeling
if major league baseball
had a culture where a 41 year old catcher
could make 300 thousand
dollars off the field
because he's a personality,
that you would see things
change systematically.
Baseball's very good at not
taking on accountability.
It's time it does and
they better move quickly
because very quickly, people are gonna be
watching video game players
throw swords at each other
instead of baseballs
and hitting with bats.
Very quickly, as a matter of
fact, it's already happened.
Now it's can they start the
process of unwinding it?
Because the days of baseball cards
in your bike spokes are over.
They're not reinvesting in their business.
They're sucking it dry and
they will play the price.
- [Phone Caller] Yeah.
- Period, end of story,
period, end of story.
Every other conversation is
the micro and is fundamentally
irrelevant to the actual
thing that's happening.
That's a lesson for
everybody in everything.
In life.